here comes a cowboy Cerrone come hello
sir welcome to the show
yeah what's going on man nada how's it
going right now we're in yeah yeah we're
on as quick oh yeah star Jason how you
doing man I'm good how you guys we're
good we're good
we're I was a I was watching some of the
videos that you were shooting in Times
Square right yesterday is the naked out
but we're trying to find him you didn't
find him no I guess he I guess he
charges 5,000 an hour know what yeah
four you can rent him there who's trying
at the UFC to rent him for an hour so
he's like no showed on us oh why so he
didn't show up to Times Square cuz he
knew you wanted him there cuz normally
there's like negotiated back and forth
and I don't know if it was him or who
someone that works I go shades for him
and so that he was like yep we'll be
right here at noon and we're like great
and then they started asking for money
so then and you she was like no we're
gonna give you tons of publicity yeah
blah blah blah anyways he didn't he was
a no-show what a dope stupid why
wouldn't you want to be associated with
such a massive event others funny yeah
yeah so instead I assumed it would be
very good that were people that people
know that you're not the real Naked
Cowboy uh he suits people over that [ __ ]
come on not like over life you really
pretend to be him like that they
wouldn't but like we had a waiter friend
who's an old lady named sandy Kane yeah
it was a sugar lady let's not yeah why
she she's an aged woman yeah but she was
a stripper for a long time and she went
out there is the naked cowgirl any
suitor that's her yeah so she was a
stripper
80 years yeah yeah I'm not very long Wow
yeah while ago okay but she went out and
said I'm the naked cowgirl and the naked
cowboy suitor for it yeah and then he
regretted being involved in litigation
with her you think she showed up for
court was actually enjoying it it was a
quite a my involvement I mean how she's
a naked cowgirl doesn't it not even the
same thing how can you sue somebody he
said it was way too close how can you
sue somebody when you're a gimmick
you're so staying I mean it's like I'm
suing Elmo and all the people down there
yeah take a picture for 5 bucks will be
like if you went out there in like a
little yellow costume it's a hi I'm
little bird Big Bird they go it's it's
it's layoffs what we're doing that's
just what it was but he didn't invent
the cowboy right no cowboy has been
around for
those naked but I guess he put them
together first I feel like I'm in a
cowboy a lot you certainly are
yeah yeah but you stay in good shape you
have a great body oh thank you yeah yes
Emma's been commenting on that
well looks are comfortable part it's not
uncomfortable for him is for not and you
know he's not looking me in the eyes
telling me that no of course not afraid
you're behind him holy yelled at over
his shoulder
but you stay in shape all the time like
you're fighting constantly constantly at
any point like that you don't go through
a period where you want to just rest
from it no I meant it's a weird feeling
like whenever as soon as I'm done in one
fight I'm always on the phone calling to
get in because I feel like almost like
I'm unemployed you'd be like you guys
doing a show today and then you're like
well what do we do next and you're like
I I don't know I guess I was wait for
them to call us and you're like no we
want to do a show next weekend like
right you know so that's how I feel I
literally feel like almost employed it
when when I go home so all I need is a
date I don't ever need a who I don't
care who it is I just need tell me the
next step in my chapter life so I can
keep moving you know but not align take
them off I screw off all the time I come
here for a week and it doesn't bother me
you know be staying busy and train all
the time allows me to come to New York
for a week and not have to thing like oh
god I got to do all these shows I got do
all this media and I got to figure out
where I can train I can just relax go
have beers hang out my friends and just
chill it doesn't bother me so I never
thought of that but yeah you guys don't
know who you're fighting from one to the
next so you're done that's like the end
of your employment temporarily literally
I mean some guys take six eight months
off you know what I mean I don't know
what they do with their bank account but
then it goes fast in mine obviously
because I need to stay busy that's what
it is you party that just staying
employed
yeah staying employed and you an aid
fight deal you saw is the first thing
that those next day fights yeah this
would be the first the next day fights
and what's the timeframe for it two
years two years yeah oh wow yeah Wow so
your contract you that but that's that's
what you're contracted to do like you're
gonna do gonna do it for fight at least
at least maybe more I like six seven you
know that you do oh [ __ ] yeah guys say
yes you can't yes it's amazing it some
guys take so much time off in it and
it's like it's like every other card it
feels like you're on it to get the
average guys what two times your three
times its lucky yet
let's go run it what's the lowest you've
had to sit because of an injury not
nervin injured oh no problem
well I'm injured all the time but all
those injuries are so far away from our
heart that doesn't matter so just keep
moving you should work past them we're
passing men do people get because like I
feel like before guys like you were
coming around it was like the standard
right like people who are just
spectators would be like well you can
only do this two or three times a year
that's just the toll it takes on your
body and then you start showing up and
you're like no you can't you could do it
a lot more a lot of you want more often
there I'd be annoyed if I was a fighter
I feel like you're blowing it not what I
want to do a nice but as soon as a
fighter I mean the guys would be like
they all fight anyone any time until
it's time to fight anyone in town
Matthews you go in like ooh yeah that's
not good magic like you know I'm so hurt
and so it's just funny me have all these
guys that talk about like oh yeah I'll
fight anyone doesn't matter anyway let's
do it then they call upon him and
they're like all yeah well I was gonna
know so it's it's just [ __ ] you know
but whatever haven't gotten a
last-minute call once it was a great
last minute fight you've gotten or
you know as Ben Anderson was it was 10
days after a fight I just had so yeah I
was literally driving home from Vegas in
the RV and Dana called and so I just
kept up kept the but the RV rolling
straight to Boston all you just kept
driving right through Wow let me go home
still had still had blood on my shorts
from the last fight so it's good yeah
how do you do it that quick though cuz I
mean it's all mental it really sure so
you don't really have to sit there and
the only problem with the had been fight
is the fight before that was a mile jury
and he was laying on the ground I kicked
him a bunch I broke my foot so I went
into the Henderson fight with a broken
foot but mine just it is what it is so
you have a broken foot in a fight do you
know because they said Conor was hurting
here absolutely it's like so many bones
in your feet like it's saying you have a
broken foot is I mean it's not
I wasn't like crippled couldn't walk his
head like broke I couldn't I couldn't
like put a lot of pressure on just it
heals up I mean just but you just push
through it you weren't afraid of kicking
people too hard because you wanted to
avoid getting your foot broken again now
you keep kicking and every time I hear
[ __ ] break I just know that's money in
my bank
it must be a nice feeling to be just
just to be kicking somebody until your
foot breaks like you know I gave him my
best yeah like like my body said that's
it no more no more yeah it's good I but
you just keep going I hurt my foot for
eight months one time while I was
crossing the street and I stepped like
in a ditch and I twisted my ankle and I
had a boot on my foot for eight months
you ever twist your ankle all the time
yeah yeah you're able to you're able to
bounce back a little bit better though
you know Kate months off I take like the
worst pain I ever have is is when I'm on
my boat have you ever like stepped off
something and you [ __ ] hit your
little pinky toe on the corner of the
car that's like the worst pain you get I
do that a lot I hit little yeah but
fighting I mean oh they're just like
doll pain I don't know you don't really
get that hurt I guess how do you avoid
injury because you even hear my ears
bring a [ __ ] face on let's go
[ __ ] so when somebody goes like
I got injured in training so the fights
off you're like what the [ __ ] you
talking about yeah that's just so this
is what happens like I said the people
tell you what that really is did they
say they got her but that's just someone
saying like this next opponent I have
mm-hmm he sat in the contract for one
with us he made him forcing me no any
reason I want is there like always
looking for an out so as soon as they
can can say because I can't tell you
you're not hurt
right right right like if you have a
broken bone in the US you can say show
to me but I can't say you didn't pull
your back right so I can't prove you
don't have pain so they say oh oh now
they put on a fight with an excuse they
get to keep their contract they don't
look like a they don't look like they
said no to the contract you know it's
like a big it's just stupid you think
some guys really didn't scared of other
guys in 98 percent of them do that Wow
who's someone you know besides yourself
that you wish they would never pulled
out the fight five times with me oh he
has yeah we've signed the contract five
times I need you doesn't want to fight
you I don't know if it's bad I know what
it is a lot of these guys like that why
they don't fight very odd because they
look like they say they've taken so many
fights in UFC they worked away with the
ranks now they're sitting number number
five or number eight in the world now
they don't want to take they want to
hold that spot you know what I mean so
they think that them holding on to that
is is I don't know why would you want to
fight isn't he undefeated - yeah against
who
but they want afraid it gets who
[ __ ] him whatever when did you decide to
be the cowboy like when you were
fighting cuz like I always wanted
there's not a lot of I like when MMA
guys pick an identity like that like on
during like my like my guess my grandma
calls my name yeah so it was weird cuz
my whole life that my name is cowboy and
then I came to wcv first before the OSI
bottom right and then they started
calling me Don like announce me
donilon's like him is weird like walking
in places him hearing people call me
Donald and now it's back to people call
me Calvin oh yeah that's just been my
name
I just legit forever yeah my training
partner back here 15 years that's what
they call me like it's night that's like
my name you know so I don't know it's
just more Kawai of life for me than
anything what do you think of the the
title fight do you Joker and and Eddie
yeah I hope Betty got you know I'd
someone please shut this dude up he last
night he was I was gonna get on the on
the on the horn and start getting after
my decide not to because you talk about
him not people want advice he to two
times I had the obligation to fight him
and he turned down took the easier fight
so who Conor
yeah Conor when he find is for the first
time I was flying I just fought so I was
Sunday flying home Dana
calls me and asked me but if I'd to
fight Conor and that was for the Diaz
first fight and he declined me and took
Diaz on cuz Diaz was in Mexico you know
took the fight on ten days notice
whatever but why would you want to fight
me coming off a win so yeah my name is
in the Hat and Connor and his people
didn't pick me so so you get annoyed
when stuff like that happens like you
said I didn't know it when he wants to
talk about he's the best in the world
ball fight any law and then when it
comes time like there's a lot of that
people don't know about right behind the
scenes stuff but I know I knew what you
he's like yeah no no no so as we were
trying and I didn't even want to
negotiate more money I said [ __ ] you
let's go I'll fight you for whatever so
wasn't even about the money that time it
was just about he's running his mouth
about being the best yeah and this dude
same thing like last night he's good at
when cameras are on talking [ __ ] him in
the back he you don't say nothing really
no [ __ ] oh hey I've been in the back
many times them that this she's doing
here I wish a [ __ ]
would behind the thing in the Kearney oh
man yeah so and Eddie and you beaten
Eddie
right right um uh stuff I hope Eddie uh
I hope Eddie goes out there and does the
gets the win for sure
you know I'm rooting for him I wish I
had this fight this fight I was lobbying
for the Eddie fight but hey it makes
more sense for so a lot of people say
getting the corner fight
that's the money like you hear the
people on internet that's the money but
he's the money fight it doesn't work
like that I'm obligated on a contract to
make X amount of dollars no matter who I
fight unless you're a champion which
Eddie is because if you're a champion
then you get the pay-per-view dollars so
pay-per-view dollars if anywhere to
fight me probably not as many papers
bring conference that's smart fight for
for Eddie 1,000% not to pick me the pick
I understand nature so uh you know the
people say you need to take that corner
fight as the money is like nah doesn't
work like that you guys I wish wish it
did you made a lot of bonuses of like a
lot of bonuses yes just the way is that
you're like do you go out there like I
want to make that extra money I'm going
to get that bonus or can you not
strategize I don't you try because you
always want to finish somebody you know
you want your side a fire buddy I don't
ever think like that but I always [ __ ]
around with everybody and when I'm in
the back and I tell amen
don't we going after my bonuses boy you
know I definitely I definitely Lobby
around now but now you don't go out
there this think I'm going to get a
bones I'm is nice right 50 grand that's
that's nice when you knocked out Rick
story I would you you did what you did
to it would you were you aware of how
beautiful that was while you were doing
it yeah no I mean I still anything it's
that beautiful that's like this is easy
combo for hey combo I mean it's just
real basic I was like wow it was just
great but I was just a jab cross hook
with a kick you know I don't I don't
know um
it's even hard to say in a row it uh
it's fun man it I love what I do you
know um yeah it's good good times I
think now that will they let your family
come to see you or how does that work
like you know if I do a gig and then
like are going to have some people come
I get X amount of competitions how did
the UFC do that with you we have four
tickets four tickets is that for every
event was it just a free event um so
yeah my the wife and grandma and then to
my to my friends go and then we end up
buying a lot more and whatnot
do they give you a deal on when you buy
them sometime
sometimes notnot exceeding now so much
oh yeah oh no this is gonna be sold out
before it even now yeah yeah you know
before we even so that's a great card I
mean it's like just because it's New
York it's people have interested it but
there's also you know you're fighting
Kelvin Gastelum there's a lot of great
fights in this oh man from Belle to
Belle it's gonna be I mean it for
everyone listening everyone going I
wouldn't just show it's not like boxing
you know I mean don't just show up for
the Mayweather fight right I mean yeah
come early if you're if you're a fight
fan I mean that from from start to
finish this fight is going to be
unbelievable so I would definitely
recommend getting get your popcorn get
your Budweiser and get ready that's the
best part about going to UFC shows I
think is that like all of a sudden this
fight that nobody's talking about can be
a fight of the night and within six
months these guys one of the guys is now
a main event guy and if you go early you
can see you just don't know what you're
gonna see a lot of times you get there
or you'll watch like to see the main
card and you already see blood on the
floor yeah a lot of the prelims or the
mice those guys are really hungry too
man and it's like they want to make an
impression even though there's only half
the people in the arena solutely oh yeah
how does your wife deal with the fact
that you're like training and fighting
constantly it would appear yeah I mean
she she loves it I don't know she loves
me being gone all the time but we have
the ranch we have our training right in
our back yard so it's literally at the
house we train you know and she's there
well she likes the money so when she can
just I callers or Oh cuz she swipes that
credit card enjoys that right right yeah
just mind you providing how did you meet
her is she involved in fighting it all
or no no she thought she knew nothing
about I met her at a country bar
Amarillo Texas yeah she couldn't resist
my dance moves so so you're pretty
comfortable just like you're not what
you're not shy when you wanted to meet a
woman you're pretty cocky just you know
I don't know about complex example yeah
I feel I feel very comfortable you're
talking to women definitely especially
in a country bar setting yeah that's
probably where I would be least
yesterday yeah I don't think I'm not
very effective in most settings but I
mean in that one out I would really bet
low yeah
and very poorly when did you build the
wait what did you like have the ranch
and be able to train it eight years
we've had it and it's becoming a
compound we keep adding on adding on
we're building a swimming pool right now
so yeah just keep keep growing it you've
animals
yeah we've animal what do you have
everything pigs turkeys chickens well we
used to have turkeys chickens no they
got eight by the Keio so we get some
more of those but we got goats and
horses yeah
do you eat the chickens and the pigs no
the pigs we do the chickens now not
really is more trouble to pluck a
chicken's more in trouble that's where
they have them I think just because if
you have you need some cockadoodledoo
and going on in the morning right why we
have chickens just makes you feel like a
wrench yeah we don't have them right now
I have keys I have six annoying geese
you you think a guard dog is important
you need to get a couple geese let
someone come on your property the keys
don't know they go crazy
really it chase you down haul them oh
yeah uh I would annoy me so much but
they don't they don't honk at you know
it's weird I mean they do when they're
hungry if that's how you know it's time
to feed them but other than that no they
they're loud annoying whether your geese
they're not just wild geese four geese I
don't think I don't know geese could be
yeah we have domesticated have five
geese in one gander so one boy and five
girls not bad great not bad for the
gander you know you're not you a
connoisseur honks quietly and hardly so
they so someone shows up they'll let you
know that there is a stranger about
absolutely does that mean if you have a
friend over you're like well the geese
have to get used to you you know that
yeah I don't know how that works
plus we have a lot of dogs so they
barking what do you have I live here in
the city - I kind of want to get a dog
but I just I'm away too much and there's
known you know my life to take care of
it but I would love to have a dog to
come home to we have two labs a fat
little Bulldog and a Great Dane that's
great if you have all that space and a
turtle his name's ninja he's actually
tortoise how big is he suemungousaur get
him he's a Sakura tortoise oh he's gonna
be lived to be 200 years old wow that's
like Hannam down on my will he's four
years right now he's big he lives in our
greenhouse what does he eat
just plants yeah plants
marijuana all right so a ton fancy taste
very much does the turtle recognize your
reptiles have no recognition at all or
you don't know I don't know you know he
keep call you can definitely feed him
out of the hand but don't know if he if
you could feet I mean if it's me or if
you you know I don't I don't know if
there's any if he knows like oh there
you are like but he'll walk up to he's
pretty pretty you know cautious around
people but he's heavy a [ __ ] like pick
him up cool really cool he's like armor
all over his forearms and his neck he
looks like um like a ninja turtle for
sure he's badass and how old is this one
he's four years right now Bobby's gonna
live another 200 years yeah imagine that
this is big issue on the end of that I
don't know what the with how that works
but he's gonna pass him down and what
people we walk to do it to a pet store
and because we have a like a giant pond
out there that we keep fish and geese in
more than turkeys eat the fish out of
and so I have I digress cue turtles so
we've a bunch of like regular Turtles
and I went in there to buy another
turquoise like five or ten bucks with
these pet stores ridiculous so it's but
then there's this one in a cages like
what is that and it's just a huge turtle
in a little ass cage and so I just
bought it from him like man give me that
[ __ ] thing so there's a big-ass
greenhouse and eats let me taste some
organic heads of lettuce and berries
everyday cost me about twelve dollars a
day to feed this turtle unbelievable
Jesus he's better than myself my wife
says she's [ __ ] Turley's better than
us I said well I made the obligation
when I bought them I gotta keep feeding
himself you play with them $1 is not you
can do with a turtle really no he just
spent money on his Ben money eats ahead
let a head of lettuce and berries every
day
does he like to top of his head he let
you scratch his head you can scratch his
head and hold him and the only thing you
do if you wear flip-flops in the
greenhouse a little [ __ ] come over and
try and take a toe awesome done you know
yeah cuz what my I don't know why my
toes are red but I think he thinks
they're like berries or something comes
other you know get your toe
great pay attention he'll you he walk in
there so he definitely comes I don't
know if it's the attention or he thinks
you're feeding him but he'll definitely
like walk over whoever walks in there so
it's kind of cool she grow up with
animals yo yeah yeah we're getting some
great insight by the way our phone
screen or just wrote a note
that said Great Danes take massive dumps
massive and my my Great Dane has like
irritable bowel syndrome
blouson massive ha ha how do you fix
that
giant [ __ ] dog shits Oh worst yeah
it's uh that's why it's gotta weigh like
this giant um dog run with the pressure
sprayer and every every couple days you
gotta go in there and fire it up and
hose the piles of [ __ ] out so yeah it's
wild man he's there but he's an indoor
dog that Great Danes are big [ __ ] I
don't have you guys I've ever liked they
have all bark no bite right someone
walked up on he barks deep then you
actually get on each until his corrupt
on you but yeah my wife he has to be
inside is inside dog you know you wants
to sit up on your lap and he's just a
big push but don't they need no space to
like I heard they they're saying you
could leave them in sidle they don't
need to do anything so yeah that's
biggest [ __ ] hitting everywhere oh you
know what I'm thinking of I was thinking
of a greyhound oh great great great
names orgies like a small grey hound no
nice riding four runs no this is a the
case just a big ass the hugest like that
how much does he weigh well 180 I think
165 you dogs 165 to mungus he's
humongous
he's us he's a merle though that's those
are blue but he's like a spotted grey
and white kind of color but uh his
name's gage and he's unbelievably smart
you can open doors and trash cans and
yeah so he's he's more intimidating like
people walk up on him he has big deep
bark and so you're kind of yeah that's
Brandt that's pretty motivation though
to keep fighting and keep getting out of
town is you don't have to clean up all
that Joe that's a great thing you know
the fighters they come out to the ranch
they help out and have chores stuff so
it's part of one of the things that I do
is clean up Wow clean up the deal
you show me a Hector show me a picture
that's a large animal very long that's
perfect so like when you guys when
you're training my god yeah it looks
like a small but it looks like a
miniature pony yeah for sure when so
when you're when you're training guys
out there like that part of the camp is
clean up my dog [ __ ] I kind of I mean
yeah so the cool thing is is the state
of New Mexico just just came at me it's
like fresh stuff and they want to do it
called
beyond scared straight so they want to
take like the you troubled youth kids
and have them come out and stay with me
kind of like right when they're they're
either in jail or about the Gogi else in
about the rasshole get them training
teach them just the better ways of life
you know so I think it's something to be
involved with and try and try and help
so that'd be some these kids would do
you know learn learn how to run the
ranch and take responsibility and
backtalk me and get back handed so
that's did you find that because you got
into fights a lot when you're growing
out all the time did you guys a hundred
I was literally a hundred and ten pounds
in high school like anybody then I came
back from a super senior you know super
senior years when you don't make it for
you doing five I said so yeah I really
want the education yeah yeah yeah it's
good so I came back and I was like a
hundred and sixty pounds I just grew one
one year and then I was like all yeah
[ __ ] it go time we go did you
go back and then kind of go after guys
who had [ __ ] with you no no because I
was like I would just fight it in it so
they they didn't have a chance anyways
little or not I would just come unglued
on people it mean they beat me up and I
just keep coming I never stopped biting
their ankles rip don't know whatever I
had to do so there's really no way to
stop you no way zero ways that you knock
me out when you started training did
that add some dislike did you stop
getting in a non disciplined fights or
not getting no like in all these people
that are listening there's I'm sure
those guys that are just starting taking
jiu-jitsu and they're just starting
taking kickboxing and all you want to do
is like try your skills out sure so we
when I started kickboxing we went all
around the world and we go out and get
drunk and have fun and then me and my
buddies were black alright tonight only
left elbows and knees like that's all we
can use if we get in a fight so we'd
like limit ourselves to strike so it's a
game it was a game that's great because
it's not fair like I don't like to my
own horn but like it's like if I ran in
something else right now it's not even
[ __ ] close like oh that's what I do
for a living you know what I mean so you
gotta like have fun with it like our
only body shots are only late kicks and
go have a good time you tell you if you
see a guy and he's like the type of guy
that would frighten me uh you six four
three two one of those gigantic guy is
you just don't give a [ __ ] you're like
now like listen let's rewind the clock
fifteen years right because now it's a
holding story but let's say you know
back when I first started I'm not in UFC
and some guy at the bar comes love it
acting crazy I was just real calmly but
guy right dude check so don't make a big
scene like we don't
don't start yelling and get all crazy
and let all your friends know I said
it's super simple just follow me out in
the parking lot me and you go figure it
out now in the alley right now and
usually me talking people call me like
that they're like oh [ __ ] is this okay
but sometimes they do it and then we got
there you can figure it out we figure it
out listen cowboy together it takes a
big man to walk out one-on-one you know
a lot of people want to bark and scene
and get all friends hold me back so if
you just call me say hey man check up
your if you're really that badass just
don't say a word mean you'll walk out
back we'll figure this out see I try
just the opposite like man I'd love to
but I don't want to get in trouble yeah
I make it look like it's a legal issue
years ago there wasn't much trouble now
I'm sure you can you can get getting to
innocent into trouble but yeah bandulus
I mean if the cops come by dust y'all if
they get us home you know so so if you
want to see cowboy fight you can't see
it at a bar no it's November 5 November
12 yeah you got to pay good money
I think tickets car self-right and road
rage me then tickets go on sale Friday
they're gonna sell out easily so be an
amazing contribution of the cards ever
if not the best card to put together yet
and that they have their cell telling us
you have to wrap up cuz you have TV to
do yeah so we'll take it we'll take a
quick single yeah buddy don't have top
what's wrong you want my favorite
fighters so I'm really happy that you're
on this drug thanks guys